he landed it
another great homage to bruce right
there that's sitting on the knocked out
body it's amazing there's not a single
simulated person there you think stunt
men are tough stump women
by far the toughest
thanks to skillshare for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to see how
you can get a free trial of a premium
membership
hey welcome back to another episode of
stuntman react we are here
with our friend gee yeah
hey what's up guys we're back
at least he didn't struggle on the
friend's part
we're back with our very best friend gee
da silva it's always a good time
when you come and react to stunts here
it's the day before valentine's day
so we're pulling up some very special um
love related scenes
bringing up very specific lovers
quarrels related scenes
for ghee today yeah all right let's just
jump let's just jump in
you still alive baby we're gonna do a
little lover's quarrel here from the
famous movie mr mrs smith starring brad
pitt and angelina jolie dude
brad pitt he's like the hottest dude
ever
angelina and angelina angelina is the
finest i know
oh man the two of them are like the
world's
sexiest two people
and central boom that was a stunt right
there that was nice
it's crazy like you think stuntmen are
tough stunt women by far the toughest
because
look what she's wearing yeah you can't
fit pads under that
he went through that glass oh that is
him yep dang
yeah i mean brad's done legit stuff that
fight he did in once upon a time in
hollywood it's pretty great
[Music]
oh clap that would hurt no matter what
yeah breakaway glass isn't it's not so
fun yeah it's not it's not pillow at all
see i never get standoffs like this you
could pull the trigger
and you'd win yeah but then it's a
question of like do you really want to
pull the trigger that's a good question
right they love each other we're talking
about valentine's day this is love
it's not mr and miss smith it's mr mrs
smith
oh that's cool they're out actually out
there doing it yep i think he has a wire
on
yeah definitely a safety line just in
[Music]
see case damn that's crazy green screen
i think so
green screen or they had like a mat but
that looks real you could tell when it's
green screen
yeah there's mediums of brad pitt but
you can't tell here this guy's like out
the door
i think he's going off to a little
platform just right outside the van and
he's just like
hugging up against the van driving with
them still yep not to take props away
from the stunt guy doing that in the
same shot but also props to brad pitt
for like doing it
and then selling that he went somewhere
else everything in he wants to
watch the guy and make sure he's the guy
right there he's alive cool that's great
brad's like as long as i kill anybody
there's the love find you somebody that
you can take out a whole bunch of goons
inside of the sports store no kick on
that shotgun
none whatsoever it's weird because like
one of the frames you could actually
see his like forearm shaking yeah well
they're definitely doing some blanks
feels like they shot this in 10 minutes
right and the crew set up you know it's
a nice pyro but it's so incidental
i kind of get the impression that they
had brad pitt and angelina jolie for
like three weeks
they're like we gotta knock out these
scenes which is that's the difference
between like john wu goes makes hard
target or mission impossible it's like
i'm gonna have a month for this fight
scene
right not to say that angeline and brad
aren't dedicated but you're talking
about tom cruise anytime about
jean-claude van damme two people who are
like dedicated to being
the action star fred and angelina jolie
both clearly want to be actors and
actresses that's what they're spending
their time doing
tom cruise wants to do the action scene
yes which is honestly like that's great
for movie making
that feels friendly and inviting to me
like that's the kind of filmmaking i
like
yeah you guys might notice that in the
background sam and spencer are working
here they are setting up a dungeons and
dragons
table here because we started filming
our show son of a dungeon which is our
take on
how to do dungeons and dragons show it's
a cool combination of visual effects
with dungeons and dragons if you guys
want to check it out it'll be a few
weeks we're working out right now but
it'll be on the website
quarterdigital.com we have a bunch of
other cool shows going up too
so go check it out
oh another hard target hell yeah i
didn't vet this clip
it's just from the ending of hard target
let's watch it
look at this guy this actor is doing a
pretty big burn too right that's a huge
bird he's like let's go
let's go shout outs to the actor for
doing this yeah that's legit that's
another like
equivalent to like seeing a your actor
do a fight scene seeing them do
something like this
it really pulls you more into the story
i have a little bit of an expectation
that if you're gonna make an action
movie and you're the actor in it you
have to
suffer a little bit for it you need to
take a hit do a role
be lit on fire if you're not going to
live any of those experiences then i
don't feel like there's
authenticity to the emotions that you're
presenting because it becomes too
fake there's a disconnect yeah right
actors if you guys want to do action you
guys claiming
that you want to do stunts you got to be
willing to do this this guy right here
badass grenade
he landed it hold on
dude he lands this front flip it's not a
dive roll it's a front flip
on his feet that's great fastest way to
get away from an explosion is the front
flip clearly
that's how i do it learned it from power
rangers
oh come on do it do it yes yes yes
the guy's a cigar
[Laughter]
oh hell yeah kill him in his life
the cinematic language here is also
impeccable and it's perfect
you know everything that's going on his
mix of like 24 frames a second
to like 48 frames a second the way he
uses slo-mo
to really understand what's going on in
this fast-paced
intense scene is masterful if that was
one scene from my video like i'd be i
consider myself a successful filmmaker
if this is the one scene i made in my
life
[Music]
harpoon wait how do they do that how do
they do that shot
it's like there's no way they would do
that for real no okay it's on a string
yeah you see the string yeah yeah yeah
yeah the string dude that's a that's a
move
simple solutions we think hollywood
movies are really complicated but a lot
of this stuff is people just being
really scrappy
oh this is a great shot a little
hard-boiled throwback here
dude it's so good that was so great
those flinches that the actors are
getting to from the explosions right
it makes it feel so real like you gotta
suffer a little bit for your art and
these guys are suffering for their art
but you know that's what you get for it
get just magnificence
boom dude the coordination
[Applause]
amazing is how you kill somebody
jump through the glass land on your back
slide under the table while shooting
bravo
bravo that was sick a good one you won't
get a more consistent
wow gun fight of anybody other than john
woo right
the king of it all of john woo's movies
are decent he knows how to build a fun
action story this is john woo
still john woo this is kind of his last
big movie that he made
dude that'd be brutal i would oh that'd
be brutal
dude
oh little achilles hunters ow
ow maybe the worst
oh oh what that was a crazy wire
yeah dude they must have had a blast
doing this
the boss with those eyebrows you know
he's got some skills
he needs new spears
this is tactical reloads with spheres
imagine getting killed by your own spear
from this guy i feel so cheated i think
this movie is a good example of maybe
going a little overly ambitious what
you're trying to do like it's fun
but you can see how like the overall
quality of each moment just goes down a
little bit because they have so much
they're trying to do
you know it's a huge war scene like it's
still incredibly
amazing that they got what they got here
but yeah i'm reading it it's all very
clear
it's just the wire work for me same
thing with the spear stuff where he's
blocking and doing a move like they're
not quite as clean the hit
strikes aren't quite exactly perfect the
framing's not quite as tied in you know
maybe focusing more on the chaos of it
all like the big picture stuff like i
really love it when you can see
tactics right like the big picture
tactics of this battle coming through
that's something i really like about the
battle of the bastards from game of
thrones yeah you can really see the
tactics and flow of battle which to me
that's that's what you need
in these scenes because the moment you
have two army lines run into each other
and then it just becomes a mess
and that was my problem with the two
towers when all the rivers approaching
the wall
it's amazing you can't wait for the
fight to begin the arrows are flying
super tactical the moment they bust the
wall
now it's 20 more minutes of shots and
somebody's swinging a sword cuts to
somebody getting hit by the sword over
and over and over
dude i never understood how
logistically you could film something
like this with so many people
and like so much potential for injury i
don't know if you can necessarily get
away with this in the united states
no to be honest with you absolutely not
oh yeah this movie
[Music]
you know they were saying when they're
filming lord of the rings the rider of
rohan charge there's the most horses
ever in a charge
i don't know if that's true anymore if
they would've had to have any horses in
the rohan charge i think they would have
had some shots like this showing it wow
wow look at that it's amazing there's
not a single
simulated person there that's crazy
that's insane dude
all the muskets going off so cool all
smoking oh my god
what a shot where's the director who's
calling action like how
do you call it yeah
dude look at that oh it goes back all
the you dude
bro it goes all the way back look at the
smoke
oh that's so cool could you imagine
filming that how sick that would be
thrilling yeah wild no steadicams or
anything just
driving in cars as fast as i can trying
to film it all the dust and the
atmosphere that helps separate
the layers of troops and everything god
dang that looks so good
so waterloo as far as i know it's a
napoleon film and they actually had 20
000 troops from the red army
moscow basically helped them out to get
these incredibly huge
shots of armies maneuvering there's
something about the style of filmmaking
where it gives you a glimpse of what it
may have actually been like
[Music]
a little piece of trivia here for you
shared from nick so they're filming a
cavalry charge in this film and the
actors playing the soldiers on the other
side got
legitimately intimidated those men on
grey horses are terrifying
they actually routed the actors and the
actors turn and ran no
way they couldn't use any of the footage
i feel at a certain point you just are
in a battle it's like i know this is a
movie but at this point i'm trying to
kill them
so i don't know if there's a cable or a
helicopter but this is one of the
coolest tracking shots i've ever seen
i think it's a cable because of how low
it gets to the ground this is the only
thing i know about this
in that exact shot you can actually if
you look close enough you can find waldo
he's in there we have like a solid 300
movies to react to
still got a lot let's just keep coming
just read the comments like oh [ __ ]
that's right there's something in that
yeah i love the fact that we can see
all these awesome new inspirations in
the comments hey this is colin push
you've seen it before but
seriously like having all these
suggestions in the comments has like
turned me on to so many
new awesome things right please continue
to leave
awesome suggestions and comments we love
it it's super helpful for the show
it means you get to see more of me at
times because if eric's not here
i get the phone that's really fun
you think you can take me on
so i brought this to you guys because i
feel like this
show warrior is one of those shows that
deserves all the flowers right now
the cool history of this show is that it
originally came from bruce lee
at the time because of how hollywood was
and how america was at the time they
felt that it wasn't a good idea to have
an asian lead
on a show anything was gonna sell so
what they did was they took his idea
and made kung fu with david carradine a
couple years back
shannon lee she finally got his dream
project made the stunt coordinator on
the job is brett chan
and his fight coordinator and assistant
stump corner is
johnny yang who's from a group of emc
monkeys really yeah yeah johnny's
awesome
we've been working with the nc monkeys
since we basically started our youtube
career
the sync movie that we made the
assassin's creed stuff we did
nerf john wick dude shout out to johnny
yang man zin isn't in this show is he
yeah you just saw him
dude there he is man and they're dude
it's the whole crew
right here our buddies just in a tv show
are you kidding me this is awesome
oh nice you're really selling these hits
really well i feel like they're doing a
little bit of visual effects also like
make the hits accelerate instantly as
opposed to people having to throw
themselves into the motion
yep cut a little frame before and after
another great homage to bruce right
there the sitting on the knocked out
body
poor guy
[Music]
dude that moved the back yeah
so sick
oh my god oh the double attack and block
at the same time
there it is deceased man
kill them group fights are always really
hard to do and this one sells it really
well there's just enough selling of the
moves that you can track it as an
audience member who's not trained
everything feels very impactful very
powerful you can read it clearly and
they're doing stuff
old school jackie old school bruce lee
incorporating that and making it modern
and this is a show that allows them to
do that and fully be aware of the fact
like yeah we're actually
paying homage to bruce lee we're
actually doing this right now like that
right the stance alone already tells you
you know the way how he's dressed
you know the classic white shirt and
black pants it's like they're taking the
techniques
of bruce his impacts and then putting
the hint of what jackie brought when it
comes to rhythms
check out warrior guys you can check out
hbo max right now
hey if you guys learned something new if
you had a good time
and we made your day just a little bit
better then go ahead and subscribe
because we do it every single saturday
and there's more fun stuff throughout
the week so hit that subscribe button
and don't
miss a video hey what's up everybody i'm
going to talk to you today about
learning in particular i'm going to talk
to you about skillshare
skillshare is an online community where
people can come together to explore
hobbies passions
and try to improve even their jobs they
have everything from filmmaking classes
to home cooking classes and anything you
can think of that might fall in between
that it's a great way to explore
a bunch of different passions that you
might have these days i've actually been
exploring
3d sculpting and virtual reality using
my oculus rift headset in the adobe
medium program now i want to see if
skillshare had anything along those
lines where i could get some tips from
other artists and to my surprise they
actually do in fact there's a staff pick
right now that's up called virtual
reality for artists how to take your
illustrations
into 3d using tilt brush taught by colin
leakes it's the kind of creativity
unlocking that you can get with virtual
reality that i'm really excited about
these days and it's cool to see
classes about that taught from other
professional artists on skillshare
skillshare is curated specifically for
learning meaning there's no ads and
there's new classes added all the time
and if you get an annual subscription
it's less than ten dollars a month so
the first thousand people to click the
link in the description below will get a
free trial of a premium membership so if
you're curious about skillshare go check
it out let's jump back in
i want to say thanks again to gee for
joining us if you enjoy his work you
want to
see what he's up to follow him on
instagram at gee ex da silva it's
awesome stuff and he's done a bunch of
other videos with us here on this
channel not just reacts we did a
learning how to stunt fall video
it was illuminating and it honestly has
kept me from getting hurt and tomorrow
we do a vfx makeover on matt's tinder
page
to see if we could you know get him a
valentine's day date by doing vfx
for his tinder pictures that's so great
so that comes out tomorrow if you guys
want to see i'm really excited to see
that
because the struggles of men on tinder i
feel for you guys
absolutely